[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 11 décembre et
l'actualité se sait se son pardon les
nouvelles annonces du premier ministre
sur les modalités de l'allègement du
confinement
le 15 décembre le retour du couvre feu
de 20h à 6h et cela inclut le soir de la
saint sylvestre pas de réouverture des
musées cinémas ou salle de spectacle
nous reviendrons en détail sur les
nouvelles règles avec différentes
réactions
cette semaine l'actualité c'était aussi
la publication des résultats d'une étude
internationale sur le niveau en
mathématiques et en sciences des élèves
de cm1 et 2 4e du monde entier et la
france n'est pas dans le haut du
classement
à ce sujet nous recevrons martin bühler
professeur émérite au laboratoire de
mathématiques de versailles de
l'université saint quentin et président
de l'association animat vice-président
pardon enfin dans l'actualité sportive
au dernier pointage l'événement louis
burton est à la sixième place du
classement comme chaque semaine nous
ferons le point sur son parcours
[Musique]
l'information du jour c'est évidemment
les nouvelles annonces du premier
ministre lors de sa conférence de presse
jeudi soir jean castex a défini les
modalités de la deuxième étape du
déconfinement prévue mardi 15 décembre
plus strictes que celles prévues
initialement
suite au nombre de contaminations qui ne
sont pas sous la barre des 5000 cas par
jour en france la première chose c'est
la fin de l'attestation 1 journée et les
déplacements entre régions sont à
nouveau autorisées mais c'est aussi le
retour du couvre feu de 20h à 6h du
matin il faudra être muni d'une
attestation spéciale le soir pour sortir
ce couvre-feu ne sera pas appliquée à
noël mais bien au jour de l'an donc le
31 décembre il sera donc interdit de
circuler entre 20h et 6h du matin ce qui
fait réagir une partie des habitants de
saint quentin en yvelines
on les écoute au micro de céline agathe
son go et justine brasil on comprends
moi lâche que j'ai bon c'est vrai que on
peut rester en couple au en petit comité
20h20 va se retrouver une raquette comme
des gens de 55 ans dont 20 pour des gens
qui ont entre 21 ou 22 romans pas le
nouvel an dont on aurait rêvé pour moi
c'est pas normal à 20 heures parce que
les gens ils vont aller visiter les
premiers pc
il faut au moins laissé jusqu'à des
notes pour la sécurité tout le monde je
trouve ça très bien que les gens se
protègent et qui respecte les eaux les
horaires on espère qu'on va quand même
le faire même si c'est pas trop légale
en vrai c'est pas top mais
et c'est pour notre moral aussi parce
qu'en plus on travaille on en est on est
jeune on nous dise tous 20 ans c'est
trop cool c'est l'année pour profiter on
est jeune on est beau on s'aime et on
peut même pas profiter ensemble et je
trouve ça hyper triste
l'autre décision et celle ci n'a pas
réjoui le monde de la culture c'est le
report de la réouverture des musées et
théâtres ou encore salles de spectacles
et mêmes des cinémas il devait rouvrir
ce 15 décembre mais vont devoir rester
fermé trois semaines supplémentaires au
minimum entre colère et déception on
écoute les réactions au micro d'astrid
bergère et nicolas landry
mais par exemple on devait accueillir la
semaine prochaine la compagnie xy c'est
une compagnie avec 21 acrobates sur
seine qui ont donc recommencé à
travailler il ya une dizaine de jours
parce qu'il ya vu ce confinement pour
être prêt et puis pour enchaîner la
tournée donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont
travaillé pendant dix jours et
qu'aujourd'hui on leur dit non vous
n'allez pas pouvoir vous n'allez pas
pouvoir jouer je pense qu'il ya une chez
pas si c'est une méconnaissance du
secteur mais là ce qui nous mettrait en
colère c'est que on a le sentiment que
c'est un choix politique c'est pas
uniquement choix sanitaires un choix
politique ça veut dire que finalement on
n'est pas un secteur non essentiel pour
le gouvernement on est un secteur
inutiles ou bien le secteur que l'on
peut toucher finalement sans que ça
fasse beaucoup de mal on attend tous que
les musées les lieux culturels les
théâtres les cinémas rouvre parce que on
en a besoin
et justement pendant toute cette période
du 1er et du 2ème confinement ce qui est
très étonnant c'est de voir la
hiérarchie de nos besoins
qu'est ce qui est essentiel qu'est ce
qui ne l'est pas quand on est artiste on
a du mal
à entendre que ne ce n'est pas essentiel
là parce qu'en fait toute notre vie en
dépend et enfin les règles sur les lieux
de culte elle reste inchangée réélection
du curé de la collégiale notre dame de
mantes-la-jolie au micro de justin brazy
les annonces sont plus douloureuses pour
beaucoup de gens je pense tous les
artistes les cinémas les théâtres et
tout ça et je pense d'abord à eux nous
on va pouvoir ouvrir on va plus on peut
déjà ouvrir avec des restrictions
donc on va s'adapter avant que la jolie
c'est spécial parce qu'on a une immense
église
donc on va pouvoir se répartir on sent
même réparti les chaises autour du coeur
là où habituellement ya pas de chaise
comment voilà emplois dans l'ensemble de
l'espace et puis on a rajouté des messes
pour pouvoir célébrer noël correctement
mais voilà on est on est dans heureux de
pouvoir célébrer noël et la naissance du
sauveur
c'est pour nous très important
l'actualité de la semaine c'est bixente
mais rien senti steban qui vous la
résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
puis mois d'emprisonnement avec sursis
et 25000 euros damende requis contre
serge marois l'ancien préfet des
yvelines comparaissent ce lundi 7
décembre devant le tribunal de
versailles
accusé de détournement de fonds faux et
usage de faux il avait déjà reconnu les
faits l'entreprise spécialisée dans les
services informatiques atos dans la
tourmente
sept cas de cancer rare du cerveau ont
été détectés parmi les salariés et
anciens salariés de la multinationale
situé aux clayes-sous-bois enquête est
en cours pour déterminer si elle est
responsable ou non le tronçon aérien de
la ligne 18 a été modifié sur le plateau
de saclay ce métro doit relier
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles à
l'horizon 2030
la société du grand paris après la
décision de construire une partie du
viaduc gros saule entre saclay et magny
les hameaux
un bouton stop sans contact c'est la
nouveauté abordé ski bus
ce nouveau système innovant mis en place
dans cinq véhicules du réseau est en
expérimentation pendant deux mois une
pièce de théâtre saint-quentinoise
c'est le projet de j'habite hashtag
saint quentin en yvelines des habitants
de cinq des douze communes ont été
choisies comme comédien représentation
le 13 février prochain au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est la bonne nouvelle de la semaine
pour le sport amateur en extérieur après
les plus jeunes la semaine dernière les
seniors ont repris les entraînement sans
contact
en attendant le retour espéré des
compétitions au mois de janvier
[Musique]
cette semaine l'actualité c'était aussi
le résultat de l'étude internationale
est là pardon davance pardonnez mon
accent trends in mathematics and sound
study autrement dit des im 2s 2019 qui
pointe du doigt le piètre niveau des
élèves de cm1 et 2 4e en en
mathématiques et en sciences
à ce sujet nous accueillons martin
andler bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
professeur émérite de l'université
versailles saint quentin au laboratoire
de mathématiques de versailles ce
laboratoire dépend du cnrs mais
également de l'oeil de l'ue vs qu alors
pour rappel c'était sud a déterminé que
la france n'avait pas de bons résultats
en maths et en sciences pour ne citer
que le niveau de cm1 en mathématiques
les élèves français n'obtiennent que 485
points quand le premier en tête du
classement singapour en à 625 en
sciences on ne fait pas vraiment mieux
aux france on a en france on obtient 488
points en cm1 et à singapour toujours en
tête 595 points voilà le classement du
niveau de 4e n'est guère mieux
martin en l'air vous êtes donc aussi
présidents vice-présidents pardon et
fondateur d' animat une association pour
l'animation mathématiques son rôle je le
rappelle est de favoriser le goût et la
pratique des mathématiques pour les
jeunes vous qui voyez du coup beaucoup
de jeunes les élèves français sont ils
aussi mauvais qu'on ne le pense alors
c'est yahia pas de moyenne il ya des
moyennes évidemment mais il ya des très
bons et il ya des élèves qui sont en
grande difficulté
c'est quelque chose qu'on sait depuis un
certain temps les ultimes ce n'est pas
très surprenante
il ya eu des études qu'il ya eu une
étude team en 2015 ya quatre ans il ya
les études pisa menée par l' ocde tout
aboutissent à peu près au même
diagnostic c'est à dire nos élèves sont
très très moyen ou même moins que moyen
médiocre et en effet les ultimes établi
qu'on est parmi les
plus mauvais des pays riches alors
ensuite ça n'empêche pas qu'il y ait des
élèves qui se sont brillantissime c'est
une moyenne
super team ce que nous apprend et qui
est relativement nouveau par rapport aux
études précédentes c'est que on a très
peu de très bon ça très peu on a à peu
près 2 % d'élèves qui sont très bons
alors que l'angleterre en a 12 ou 13
courses en tout cas un écart qui est
tout à fait significatif
c'est très préoccupant
est ce que je le rappelle nous sommes
nous la france un des derniers pays
européens dans ce classement kg et à
majorité
d'abord les cinq premiers sont plutôt
dans l'asie
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait remédier à
ce mauvais classement en france alors
chevron cc c'est très compliqué vous
savez peut-être où les éditeurs ça
peut-être qu'il ya trois ans le nouveau
ministre à l'époque lancker avait confié
à cédric villani grands mathématiciens
et les charolles torossian mathématicien
lui aussi inspecteur général le soin de
préparer un plan mathématique qui sont
très des recommandations il ya eu
beaucoup de travail
ce plan est en train d'être mises en
oeuvre donc cette on s'en occupe à mon
avis on ne s'en occupe pas suffisamment
si on ne prend pas la mesure de la
gravité de la situation
si vous pensez qu'il y à 2 % d'élèves de
4e en france qui sont de très bon niveau
ça veut pas dire très bon niveau ça veut
pas dire il s'agit pas de génie il
s'agit de gens qui ont la capacité de
suivre avec un vrai succès l'enseignant
un thématique au lycée et ensuite de
faire des études supérieures
scientifiques 2% ça fait seize mille
c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins que les
besoins qu'on a d'ingénieurs de médecins
d'économie de professeur de
mathématiques d'informaticiens donc on a
un déficit qui est extrêmement grave qui
remet en question la capacité de la
france dans dix quinze vingt ans à être
une grande nation industrielle et
scientifique
donc c'est la formation des enseignants
le programme scolaire qu'il faudrait
revoir à ce sujet en cm1 en quatrième
pour changer ça alors il ya
il ya un enjeu de formation des
enseignants on sait que les enseignants
dans le haut niveau de l'école primaire
sont majoritairement de formation
littéraire
ils sont pas à l'aise avec les maths ils
le disent d'ailleurs c'est pas une
critique qui font s'ils le sens ont
parfaitement conscience ne sont pas à
l'aise et parfois ils ont même peur des
maths et donc ils font passer vis-à-vis
de leurs élèves la peur des maths donc
là il ya un vrai souci
donc oui il faut remédier à ceux-ci on
peut le faire de différentes manières
au moment de la formation des
enseignants dans les instituts
spécialisés les fameuses insp et en
amont à l'université je pense bien en
amont vous savez que nous lycéens ont la
possibilité de faire lorsque l'arrêté en
arrêtant complètement les mathématiques
au niveau de la classe de première
c'était vrai dans l'ancien lycée c'est
vrai dans le nouveau lycée c'est un vrai
problème
il faudrait qu'il y ait des
mathématiques pas les mêmes pour tous et
des mathématiques obligatoire au niveau
du lycée est alors très rapidement un
dernière question nous sommes en pleine
crise sanitaire et pendant le premier
confinement les élèves ont été confinés
les écoles fermées est-ce que ça va
accentuer selon vous ce mauvais
classement se mouvait niveau des élèves
français en maths et en sciences
alors enfin là tout le monde est à la
même enseigne sont les pays asiatiques
ils s'en sortent mieux que tous les pays
occidentaux souffrent un peu des mêmes
difficultés le continent
l'école en ligne je pense que oui on
sait d'ailleurs nous on le voit
l'université avec nos étudiants ceux qui
ont été continués mission d'arriver à la
rentrée ils ont des cours en ligne
c'est extrêmement difficile pour eux de
se mobiliser autour des enjeux
d'enseignement je pense que ça va en
particulier aggraver les inégalités
sociales qui sont extrêmement forte en
france mais merci beaucoup martin de
l'air d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
journal c'est bon
[Musique]
on vous présente maintenant une
profession assez insolite baptiste
girardet est ce que l'on appelle un
nettoyeur de crime
son métier est de passer après la mort
pour cela il a créé sa société sang
froid en 2010 est basé à triel sur seine
avec la crise sanitaire de nombreuses
personnes font appel à lui pour des
désinfections liés aux covit 19
reportage baptiste girardet donne ses
consignes et il est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un nettoyeur de crime
pourtant depuis la crise sanitaire le
fondateur de la société sang froid à
adapter quelque peu son activité il
s'est lancé dans la désinfection lyoko
vite 19 on désinfecte les habitats privé
pour les gens qui reviennent de
ranimation et qui ont eu comme idée qui
ont la chance de revenir chez eux mais
essentiellement pour la partie
commerçants artisans qui doivent
pérenniser finalement leur activité
quand cela est permis de manière à
désinfecter leurs environnements de
travail ce jour-là baptiste girard des
intervient chez deux commerçants l'un à
coignières et l'autre à rambouillet au
programme des infections de l'ensemble
de leurs locaux et traitement à l'ozone
nous sera qu'embrasse un petit peu plus
de monde
du coup les gens je préfère qu'ils se
sentent en sécurité en nombre magasins
entre guillemets clinton nous cueillir
donc je pense que c'est important d'en
prendre soin pour nous ce qui est
important c'est que l'on soit seront que
nos clients aussi qu'ils soient rassurés
qu'on puisse avoir des lieux saints
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
sang froid a réalisé 170 interventions
créée en 2017 ce n'est pourtant pas sa
mission première
devenir nettoyeur de crimes n'étaient
pas forcément non plus la vocation
initiale de baptiste gérard d d'abord
pompiers de paris pendant 11 ans puis
criminaliste y siens de sécurité
intérieure dans la police scientifique
pendant trois années
il a tout lâché pour créer son
entreprise un jour j'en ai eu marre j'en
ai eu marre de aussi bien de voir dans
parcours pompiers que dans le parcours
police scientifique des familles des
gens désoeuvrés
en attendant un service qui n'existait
pas qui justement un service qui puisse
effacer les traces de la mort une fois
qu'on est décédé on rentre dans un état
de putréfaction le corps fourie
finalement et donc laisse des traces les
fluides humains qui sont contenus dans
le corps
s'échappe pas gravité donc il y en a sur
le sol sur le mobilier sur lequel repose
le départ cette décision il l'a prise en
toute connaissance de cause l'idée
d'être nettoyeur de crime fait suite à
deux drames familiaux qu'il a vécu en
2003 et 2004 2003 c'était aussi la date
dans près
à laquelle j'ai été incorporé chez les
pompiers de paris donc on découvrait
nombre de cadavres tous les jours due à
la canicule justement et je me suis tout
de suite posé cette question je pouvais
pas présager que quelques semaines plus
tard j'allais faire la douloureuse
expérience des fluides de mon
grand-oncle que j'ai dû moi-même
nettoyer puisqu'elle bailleur parisien
m'a donné 10 jours pour vider un
appartement parisien
aujourd'hui la société sont froids en
bouche quatre personnes à plein temps et
fait appel à des freelances lorsque
l'émission s'accumulent partis se former
au canada
baptiste girardet espère bien un jour
voir une formation de nettoyeur de crime
naître en france
enfin comme chaque semaine un petit mot
de voile y vivent du roi louis burton
participe au vendée globe 2020 il a fait
plus de 40% de la course le skipper de
35 ans originaire de rambouillet est
actuellement en 6e position sur ce tour
du monde en solitaire et sans escale il
a donc perdu du terrain par rapport à la
semaine dernière
la raison il a décidé de s'orienter vers
des eaux très au sud de l'océan indien
il a enregistré cette vidéo cette
semaine regardez
alors pour ceux qui se demandent
pourquoi j'étais dans cette donnée a pas
de vent c'est pas dans mes habitudes et
va en fait c'est parce que j'avais
besoin de répondre à une problématique
qu'on m'a posée comment tu déchires des
moines
voilà
voilà à quoi ressemble un atelier
voilerie
les noms dont les gens voient
le fait d'être ici
comme il ya tout en trouvant trop ce
n'est que dans le bateau six nuits c'est
le moyen celui de venir dans cette zone
sans vent
[Musique]
j'ai plein d'oiseaux des albanais moi
c'est un fait
là je rejoue franc maçon
parce que forcément ça me fait perdre du
terrain mais j'ai déjà pu réparer
complètement marre presque complètement
ma grand voile
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté
par grégory canal et avant cela vous
pourrez revoir cette émission et toutes
les autres sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme ou bien sur notre
application mobile tv 78 et d'ici là je
vous souhaite un très bon week-end et
une très belle soirée
[Musique]